الشمالية قد تغرق جارتها
الجنوبية بالصواريخ. والولايات
تستخدم الاسلحة النووية وسط قد
تغزو تايوان قريبا. وكوريا
احد مرافقيه برصاص مسلحين
مجهولين في مأرب. روسيا قد
الالزامية. مستشار وزير الدفاع
اليمني اللواء محمد الجرادي مع
الكوريتين وكوريا الشمالية تهدد
بالرد حيث قالت ان اطلاق
دول الخليج ونتطلع للانتقال من
التعاون الامني والدفاعي لمختلف
التراشقات الكلامية اتهامات
متبادلة بالاستفزاز بين
اسلحة مع روسيا ولن نعقد. نعم
المجنون يقولها نمتلك كل ما يكفي
تصدر بيونج يانج بيانا ردا على
واشنطن تقول فيه لن نعقد اي صفقة
الجوي بعد اربعة ايام من اطلاقه
في الوقت الذي يؤكد خبراء من ان
خلال ذلك كانت اسبانيا قد قررت
ايقاف ثلاثمائة رحلة جوية والسبب
السبعة بشأن تايوان ونعتبره
تدخلا في خلافات داخلية صينية
مقاتلات وسفنا حربية. فهل حان
وقت الغزو? هنا يظهر الرئيس
كثيرة لتعلن تايوان رصد تحركات
عسكرية صينية في محيطها تتضمن
ونحن في انتظار زيارة تبون الى
موسكو. لتذهب موسكو لما هو ابعد
وزير الطاقة التركي مصرحا ان
انقرة قد بدأت بالفعل شراء الغاز
ان المشاكل الموجودة يجب حلها عن
طريق الحوار فهل سيتوسط بوتين
من الشركات الغربية في مجال
التعاون العسكري من المانيا
معركة الطاولات والهدف كسب
المزيد من الحلفاء لتأمين
والولايات المتحدة وبولندا
وبريطانيا. ومن حرب العقوبات الى
ثقتها وخطر جديد يهدد البحرية
الروسية حيث دعت لحملة تبرعات
كبير وستجعل مجالهم الجوي اكثر
كما تقول كييف. نعم كييف تعزز
المضاد ومنح روسيا الوقت
لاستعادة الموارد. لتعلن وزارة
هذا الطباخ البيت الابيض يجيب.
اخبار تدخل الروس في انتخاباتنا
تظهر المخاوف بين المسؤولين
الامريكيين من لعبة روسية قد
طباخ بوتين ويفجر المفاجأة نعم
رجل الاعمال الروسي المقرب من
النصفي واول قرار لهم سيكون
ايقاف الدعم عن اوكرانيا هنا
هذا? وزير الطاقة محمد عرقاب من
المتوقع ان تفوق مداخيل الجزائر
المجالات الاقتصادية. اردوجان في
الفين وثلاثة وعشرين سننقل
تبقى القدس العاصمة الموحدة
لاسرائيل. ما الذي تتحدث عنه يا
بيونج يانج كلما تواصلت التحركات
الاستفزازية سيرد الجيش الكوري
تتعالى نبرة التصعيد في شبه
الجزيرة الكورية لتندلع حرب
المناورات المشتركة التي اجرتها
كوريا والولايات المتحدة. واضافت
لردعكم ليضيف بيان لا تصدق
امريكا فهي تنشر الشائعات. هناك
صاروخ صيني تائه اطلقه الصينيون
وقد عاد الصاروخ الى الغلاف
الكوريتين. كل ما يثير الحروب ها
هو يحدث وبشكل يومي والزعيم
الصيني شي جين بينغ سيزور
السعودية في الاسبوع الثاني من
الشرق الاوسط لتخرج بكين بتصريح
شديد اللهجة نرفض بيان مجموعة
خيارا سوى الاستمرار في دعم
اوكرانيا لكن في الولايات
الامريكية مرة اخرى وتصرح انها
لم ترى اي مؤشر يدل على استعداد
اكد الكرملين انفتاح روسيا على
الحوار ولكن في الوقت المناسب
تبقى اسرائيل المسيطرة امنيا على
منطقة غرب نهر الاردن ويجب ان
يهتمون لتهديدات ولا ينظرون الى
الخلف. كل ما في الامر انهم
وبعد ان اعلنت الجزائر تقدمها
بطلب رسمي للانضمام الى مجموعة
لاية حرب محتملة. بينما كشفت
صحيفة الامريكية ان الرئيس
مقدمة عرضا لايران والسعودية
للوساطة في حل الخلافات مؤكدين
البريطاني ريشي سوناك محظوظون
بعلاقاتنا المهمة والتاريخية مع
كوريا الشمالية تتحدى نفذنا
تجاربنا الاخيرة لمحاكاة ضرب
الموت العسكرية المشتركة بين
امريكا وكوريا الجنوبية. ها هي
العراقي يراجع مناقشة مشروع
قانون الخدمة العسكرية
ديسمبر المقبل في اطار قمة
منتظرة بين البلدين. واعتبرت
الصحيفة ان الزيارة من شأنها ان
تؤكد نفوذ بكين المتنامي في
الكوري لا يتوقف عن ممارسة
هوايته المفضلة. ومع هذا كله
احتمالية الحاق الضرر بالارض
جدا. ردود المجنون لا تتوقف. بين
تستضيف دولة شرق اوسطية كأس
العالم. بنيامين نتنياهو يجب ان
من المحروقات خمسين مليار دولار
نهاية العام الجاري. البرلمان
بقرن تركيا. وزير الخارجية
القطري هناك من لا يتقبل ان
بلادنا الى المكانة التي تستحقها
من خلال تمسكنا بوعودنا المتعلقة
من موسكو بالروبل. هنا يتألم
الدولار الامريكي. ومن جانب اخر
الاقتصاد والتأييد الدولي. وزير
خارجية الهند. روسيا شريك موثوق
لفك هذه العقدة? الصين لا
تتراجع. اصحاب العيون الضيقة لا
يتقدمون نحو الهدف بصوت عال
احيانا وبصمت مطبق في احيان
بالنسبة والتعاون كبير لا سيما
ما يتعلق بموارد الطاقة. ليخرج
بريكس. روسيا تعلق نرحب برغبة
الجزائر بالانضمام الى بريكس
بل على العقوبات الغربية وذلك
بفرضها عقوبات على اربع وسبعين
العالم اجمع. وعلى اصوات طبول
المعارك وادخنة الحروب. هنا نائب
الدفاع الاوكرانية ان انظمة
الدفاع الجوي سامسو اسبيد وصلت
الى اوكرانيا وهذه الاسلحة ستعزز
قدرات الجيش الاوكراني الى حد
الامريكية. وقال بريجوجن خلال
عملياتنا الجراحية والتي ستكون
اهداف في وكوريا الجنوبية.
الاحداث والتطورات. رئيس الوزراء
كبيرة من اجل تمويل صفقة شراء
مسيرات بحرية تهدد الاسطول
بانتظار الرد الروسي. بينما
روسيا ترد بالمثل ولكن ليس على
الشمالي باجراءات عسكرية حازمة
وكاسحة. وبعد ان انتهت مناورات
الصواريخ الباليستية خلال الايام
الماضية هو الرد الواضح على
يعلنها صريحة. لست بحاجة لاحد.
فلدي ما يكفي من الاسلحة. فما
على هيروشيما وناجازاكي ليتحدث
بوتين قائدا لماكرون. لا داعي
تتغزل بدول الخليج وهنا اليمن
يعلن عن اغتيال مسؤول رفيع.
مجموعة السبع وتزيد من نفوذها في
الشرق الاوسط. بينما كيم جونج
الصيني قائلا بلادنا ستعمل بشكل
شامل لتعزيز العسكرية والاستعداد
لتؤكد امكانية الدخول في مفاوضات
جورنال تقول ان الغرب لا يرى
الروس للدخول في مفاوضات بحسن
نية. هنا تبدأ المؤشرات في ظهور
البحري الروسي بعد نجاحها في
اصابة سفن حربية روسية في
تغير مسار الانتخابات النصفية
لتتلاعب باهواء الناخبين. ليخرج
بوتين ومؤسس مجموعة فاغنر يقر
بالتدخل في الانتخابات
وزير الخارجية الروسي اندري
رودينكو لا توجد شروط مسبقة من
جانبنا باستثناء الشرط الرئيسي
ان اوكرانيا حسن النية. وهنا يرد
مستشار الرئيس الاوكراني وقف
اطلاق النار يعني وقف هجومنا
ليست مفاجئة ولا تخبرنا انه شيء
جديد او مفاجئ كما نعرفه. ويعرفه
متناهية الدقة سنستأصل الكليتين
والكبد دفعة واحدة. فعن اي يتحدث
معاهدة ستارت الجديدة. هنا
تستأنف المحادثات النووية خلال
المتحدة قد يتغير الحال ان فاز
الجمهوريون بانتخابات الكونجرس
مع مسؤولين روس للحد من مخاطر
استخدام الاسلحة النووية في حين
الانسحاب الامريكي من افغانستان
مستشار الامن القومي جيك سوليفان
موسكو تخترق واشنطن. بوتين يظهر
مجددا في رسالة اقل ما يقال عنها
لمهاجمة المدن الكبرى من اجل
الانتصار. فالمدن الصغيرة بينما
اتفقنا على اجتماع مع الروس في
المستقبل القريب وذلك بشروط
اسابيع بين واشنطن وموسكو بحسب
بلومبرج لتعود وزارة الخارجية
فمتى سيكون الوقت المناسب يا
هذا? لتصرح الخارجية الامريكية
فتيل القلق والرهبة وذلك
بالاشارة الى الهجومين النوويين
سرب ايضا الاعلام الغربي اخبارا
عن محادثات اجراها مهندس
وقد نشرت تقريرا يتحدث عن محادثة
هاتفية مسربة بين ماكرون وبوتين
والتي كانت بدايتها من الرئيس
الروسي الذي اشعل بهذه المكالمة
اوكرانيا بينما تنتظر كييف سلاحا
من نوع اخر. روسيا تعلن لقد حان
الصين لقد طفح الكيل ويجب ان
تعلم حدودكم. نعم. هنا بكين تؤدي
انها مرعبة ليدخل الغرب في تفكير
عميق. ووفقا لصحيفة ديلي ميلان
لموسكو وتطالب بالتفاوض سرا
وجهرا والاسلحة الغربية تنال على
الوقت لفرض العقوبات على الغرب.
فما هي تلك العقوبات يا ترى?
يثير هلع الغرب بمكالمة مع
ماكرون. تفاصيل هذه المكالمة
بعرض الجزائر ليشد تبون حقائبه
ويذهب الى موسكو بينما بريطانيا
المتحدة لا تكف عن التهديدات.
فهل اقتربت النهاية?
وموسكو تقدم عرضا لايران
والسعودية وواشنطن تكرر طلبها
الذي يقوله المجنون? اعتذر. اقصد
زعيم كوريا الشمالي بوتين يقبل
لا لا لا داعي للنووي في المدن
الكبيرة الصغيرة ستكفي. بوتين